no one could ever ever put me through
that pain again
azim rafiq's powerful testimony about
the abuse he suffered while playing for
yorkshire has brought cricket to what's
being described as a critical moment
england the wilds cricket board chief
executive tom harrison says the
allegations of racism have been like an
earthquake
the game has been uh forced into a and
rightly so forced into a period of great
introspection to uh to resolve one of
the greatest challenges i think that
we've faced as a sport and that is that
obviously to tackle discrimination and
to
uh the the
effectively the realization that your
sport is not as welcoming a place as it
should be for uh
for communities who have
felt excluded the action plan will see a
full-scale review in advance of the 2022
season
multi-faith rooms alcohol-free zones and
food and beverage for people of all
faiths there'll be a full review of
dressing room culture and action to
progress players from diverse
backgrounds in professional teams this
is going to you know change cricket you
know for a very long time and it's just
absolutely massive you know this is a
massive moment for the ecb
while the past few weeks have been
extremely damaging one player who has
suffered racism within the sport and has
played professionally for essex kent and
the pakistani team lahore says there is
now hope that change is coming
i think it's a stepping stone and taking
it into the right direction because
previously these things were never even
spoken about yet alone you know actually
dealt with so to become to come this far
it's actually a refreshing thing as a as
a player side of things there will also
be sanctions for any discriminatory or
abuse of crowd behavior from next season
well there has been vociferous criticism
of tom harrison's performance through
all of this but he insists he is the
right person to deliver the change
that's needed
the ecb says this plan is the whole game
coming together to make cricket a more
inclusive sport
so that nobody will ever have to go
through
what azim rafiq and others have
ended brady sky news at lourdes